have you ever wondered how tesla cars
are made well today i will answer part
of that question by telling you how
tesla makes its car bodies using
machines known as giga presses time and
time again elon has reminded us that
tesla gigafactories are the company's
actual product and the cars are just a
byproduct and giga presses are an
integral part of all tesla gigafactories
so join me as i look more into giga
presses to figure out why tesla
developed the machine but before we go
any further let me explain first what a
gigapress actually is what is the
gigapress a gigapress is the largest die
casting machine in the world to date it
weighs up to 430 tonnes and is 20 meters
long 7.5 meters tall and 6 meters wide
with a clamping force of up to sixty one
thousand kilonewtons because of its size
it can cast extremely large components
like car parts at this size it takes
over twenty flatbed trucks to transport
just one giga press if it ever needs to
be moved or delivered so a giga press is
basically a gigantic machine that molds
and casts out complete sections of cars
much like how toy cars are made with
molten plastic by injecting it into
moulds of course the giga press works
under the same principle but it is on a
rather large scale and uses molten
aluminum alloy instead of plastic
currently the intra group and lk group
are the only ones making the gigapress
machines with tesla being the first car
manufacturer to use them since the
announcement of this revolutionary
development many people in the die
casting industry eagerly awaited to see
the largest diecasting machines
operational fortunately for them and us
that happened a couple of years ago but
how did the gigapress come to be how did
the gigapress come to be well it is
important to note that die casting has
always been an effective way to mass
manufacture and that it has been done
for many years in car manufacturing the
only difference is that die casting was
mostly used to make smaller parts which
were then assembled together however
with the gigapress the idea was to use
it to manufacture a much larger parts
that could be assembled much more
efficiently and faster so at tesla while
elon musk and the tesla team of
engineers were looking for ways to make
the tesla cars cutting edge the
manufacturing process of the electric
car also had to fit that definition they
collaborated with another team of
brilliant engineers to create a machine
that casts entire sections of vehicles
at a go not only did this speed up the
manufacturing process but it also
increased efficiency although both
companies have enjoyed the great success
of the gigapress their individual
stories differ regarding how the
gigapress came to be on the one hand
elon said that they called the six major
press manufacturers worldwide to find
out if they could build a machine large
enough to allow tesla to cast their
vehicle frames in a single shot five of
them said no and only one of them said
maybe they went with the maybe which has
been a successful turn of events the
press manufacturer that said maybe was
the idra group an italian company with
years of experience manufacturing
die-casting machines that are used
worldwide when addressing how the
gigapress came to be the general manager
of the idra group ricardo ferrario said
the idea came to him in a dream and he
woke up with the mission to create the
world's largest casting machine elon's
call just happened to be a coincidence
one thing is for sure they are both very
good storytellers i'll give them that i
believe both stories could be true and
we can chalk this up to a classic case
of at the right place at the right time
well after that call the first
customized giga presses for tesla were
delivered and became operational in 2020
at the tesla fairmont factory these were
called die-casting machines one and two
or dcm1 and dcm2 not a lot of thought
was put into naming them i see then
again they weren't made for their names
the two were made to cast single-piece
rears after the pair's success the ol
6100 cs model was developed for tesla's
german gigafactory followed by the
impress plus dcc 6000 model made for the
chinese gigafactory the german and
chinese-based gigapresses brought with
them the development of stamping out the
rear section and the front using the
gigapress has revolutionized the
automobile manufacturing process by
doing away with the age-old tradition of
casting smaller components that are
later put together with the gigapress
car manufacturers can now enjoy the
benefits of faster more precise and more
efficient processes just as tesla has
been currently tesla only has to deal
with three chassis parts of the car the
front structure the rear structure and
the car bed ultimately making the
production of tesla cars the cheapest in
the electric car manufacturing sector so
how does the giga press actually work
how does it work well the giga press
uses two sets of ovens that handle the
aluminum alloy one is a melting oven
powered by natural gas it operates at a
temperature of 850 degrees celsius the
other oven stores the liquid metal
heated by electrical power and operates
between temperatures of 750 and 850
degrees celsius at the core of the die
casting mechanism is the gigapress it
has a similar construction to any
regular high-pressure die-casting
equipment and functions like one except
that it is enormous in size first you
should note that these huge machines can
apply a clamping force of 55 000 to 61
000 kilonewtons working on a molten
aluminum alloy of up to 80 kilograms the
molten aluminum alloy from the ovens is
injected into the casting mold at very
high speeds then the press is closed
after about 90 seconds the casting is
completed and the mold is cooled to a
temperature of 185 degrees celsius two
minutes later the next cycle begins the
gigapress's speed allows for an output
rate of between 40 and 45 castings every
hour making more than 1 000 castings per
day as if that was not enough this whole
process is automated with no humans
involved in operating the gigapress in
true elon musk style robots are
specifically designed to perform some of
the tasks that keep the gigapress
operational and productive all day some
robots lubricate the mold at the
beginning of each cycle then there is
one that injects the molten alloy into
the mold and one that removes the
casting after the process is complete
and dips the casting into a water tank
another robot cleans the mold in
preparation for the next cycle but while
cleaning is done the finished casting is
put through a mechanical press to trim
off the excess aluminum alloy by another
robot the trimmed off scrap aluminum
alloy is shredded and the offcuts are
utilized for the next casting cycles
after trimming the casting is x-rayed
for quality control and the final robot
in this process a laser-guided robot
drills in all the holes that will be
used to assemble the casting with other
sections of the car that is the process
of how one gigapress and its
accompanying robots work to make one
section of a car why is the gigapress
important to tesla remember how i
mentioned earlier that according to elon
tesla's actual product is its factory
well this is the reason why the
gigapress is so important for tesla it
can all be summed up in one word
efficiency a giant die-casting machine
that can produce entire car segments in
one go makes tesla's factories and the
entire manufacturing process extremely
efficient with downstream benefits all
along the production line other big auto
manufacturers like toyota and honda also
use die casting in their production
lines but none of them thought to
develop a machine that can cast entire
segments of a car's body in one go they
still use a slightly antiquated
technology of stamping and welding
pieces together therein lies the genius
of the gigapress it eliminates the need
to produce multiple segments and casted
components are structurally more sound
as it reduces multiple points of failure
elon said in an interview that using the
gigapress to cast the rear underbody
assembly on a model y allowed tesla to
go from making 70 small parts to one
giant part eliminating 300 assembly
robots and reducing the body shop space
by 30 similarly they eliminated another
300 robots for the front underbody
assembly this way tesla's new giga
berlin and giga texas factories are the
most efficient car production lines in
the entire industry tesla's cash
conversion cycle which is to say the
time it takes to convert cash into a car
and then sell that car to generate cash
flow was negative 15 days in 2021. this
means that tesla cars are sold even
before they had to pay to manufacture
them by comparison toyota's cash
conversion cycle in 2021 was 31 days and
volkswagens was at 74 days hopefully you
can now see what having a super
efficient production line with the
gigapresses means for tesla not only
that but it has also led tesla to claim
a profit margin of over 30 percent on
its cars this is insane in the
automotive world and it is all thanks to
the giga presses so why did tesla
develop the giga presses simply to
disrupt the automotive manufacturing
process once and for all well what do
you think of the gigapress do you think
tesla will reach a point where they can
use a gigapress to make the entire car
chassis in one go let me know down in
the comment section below if you enjoyed
this video hit the subscribe button and
continue watching the next video by
clicking on one of the cards on your
screen see you in the next one